When Harry Met Harry Plus everything you
need to know about the game of Thrones
premiere and of course Beyonce's twins
those were her babies and this one's
mine
happy Friday friends this is the daily
Denny Webb Beyonce's only lent is a lot
of the extra today thank you we go it is
the day we've been waiting for I know
I'm not just talking about new music
Friday Beyonce got her babies
information for one gorgeous
over-the-top first photo of the one
month old twins by now you've seen it
but look at it study it let's dissect it
because there are some Easter eggs the
Rosel filled backdrop looks just like
the one where she first cradled her
growing baby bump to announce she was
pregnant and the flower mother earth
motif has been something queen bee has
been so committed to you saw it at the
Grammys and you've seen it on her
Instagram page now et has learned that
the photo of Sir Andrew B Carter was
snapped at that stunning Malibu estate I
told you guys she and jay-z have rented
for the summer those babies look like
they got jazz lips and one of them has a
full head of hair but it's Beyonce's
mid-drift I can't stop staring at like
this woman just had twins this all went
down around 10 p.m. last night while
half the country was asleep this was
also around the time she and hubby jay-z
were at a listening party for rock
nation artist vic mensa
now I know yesterday I showed you guys a
very blurry pic of the two and join from
sushi in Malibu
today I've done you one better because
here they are enjoying their low-key
date night and clearly it looks like the
baby weight is coming off quickly
because B looks amazing the pic of the
twins got 2 million likes in less than
an hour including one from Kim
Kardashian now that's a big deal
considering there was a report that
Kanye left jay-z's title over an alleged
money dispute either way this got the
Beehive in a frenzy and for good reason
and this photo is on track to becoming
instagrams most liked photo ever beating
out her own pregnancy pic so there you
have it
just too much excitement for a Friday
and there's so much more because watch
what happens when
pop royalty meets British royalty that's
right Harry Styles met Prince Harry the
real deal royal look frigging dapper as
ever when he attended the London
premiere of Harry's new world war two
epics Dunkirk the two exchanged a hearty
handshake and while we don't know it
exactly what they talked about we can
share pretend alright pull that photo
back up right here we go
hmm hello Harry Oh massive massive fan
man how you doing you all right I'm all
right Prince great to see you big fan as
well
oh yes can I get a signed copy of one of
your 1d albums oh sure no problem Harry
Prince for Princess Charlotte no
actually it's for my girl Megan mark Oh
Harry you scallywag baby thank you very
much bye Oscar all right now Dunkirk is
Harry's big-screen debut but don't bank
on him ditching his music career just
yet the former One Direction singer told
reporters at the premiere he thinks he
peaked and he may be one and done all
right Harry you say that now but just
wait until Game of Thrones called
I bet you'll be on it all right lucky
for you guys the HBO smash have cast
another fine British singer for a cameo
in their upcoming seventh season but I
know that's not the only thing Westeros
fans cannot wait for keen as it's been
385 days since the last season that's
why I've called in some serious
reinforcements please welcome back our
resident TV expert Liane Aguilera hey
Denny hello girl I know what your fans
but you are one of the lucky ones who's
actually seen the premiere what do you
want fans to know about it oh my gosh
well first of all it is amazing and I
got to say the very first scene will be
the moment that is going to shock
everyone also surprisingly it's one of
the funniest episodes the show has ever
done so that was crazy to see and since
there are only seven episodes in the
seas instead of the usual ten it will be
incredibly action-packed no duds here I
mean is there ever on this show come on
all right we learned earlier this year
that Ed Sheeran will make a cameo what
can we expect well first of all he's
actually making this cameo because
Maisie Williams who plays Arya Stark is
one of his biggest fans and you
secular producers plan to give for
something a little special I'm not going
to say when this cameo is going to
happen but edie has said that he is
serenading Newsies character so consider
us all extremely jealous take a look at
what else Edie told us about his guest
spot I haven't seen it yet I just know I
just know the scene I did I did with
Maisie and it's nice I like it I like
nothing exciting happens in the scene we
just have a conversation that's kind of
it I didn't put on my thermal socks and
I was outside in the winter in England
for about 10 hours so it was cold that's
not very interesting for anyone watching
at home but here I feel like my cameo
has been threw up too much then people
will just be like oh all right like it's
not an integral part of it at all I'm
just like in it it's definitely worth it
well good
all right Game of Thrones season 7
premieres Sunday night and on Monday
morning Leanne will have your full recap
in our new show aptly titled Westeros
weekly every Monday only on ETV YouTube
channel thanks leo
thanks Denny don't miss westeros weekly
guys tuna please alright before we sign
off it is new music Friday and I got to
tell you it was honestly so hard to
narrow down this week there are so many
jams but we've got a hot one from Demi
Lovato who dropped sorry not sorry
earlier this week she wails on this
thing and you need to hear it
[Music]
it's all good oh I'm sorry that is
officially my new shower jam you know
the one when you're in the shower just
like seeing you try to get that for a
chair turn uh-huh okay so in the hip-hop
world French Montana's new album jungle
rules is out today and the track I've
got on repeat is called ally with the
weekend yet my love aside for the time
[Music]
Oh God
I already stuck in my head for real and
finally one of my favorite DJ's seed
just teamed up with One Republic for
their new single and the perfect song
for all of you poolside this weekend
tickle drink you all damn night picture
just poolside sipping on a cocktail
listen to that jammer are you guys there
you have it now go and enjoy your
weekend everybody we'll be back on
Monday with a new daily Denny so
subscribe to e t--'s youtube channel now
and also because starting thursday we
are coming to you live from comic-con I
cannot wait for that you guys stick with
ET online.com for the latest in
entertainment until Monday bye